hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy happy international women's day
and in honor of international women's
day we have a special guest someone who
i know quite well
khan academy's chief people officer
regina ross we're going to talk about
her journey and careers and developing
careers as a woman or or as anyone
but before we jump into that
conversation i'll give my standard
announcement first of all a reminder
that we are a not-for-profit at khan
academy so if you're in a position to do
so please think about going to khan
academy.org
donate donations of all size make a huge
difference i also want to give a special
shout out to many folks who supported
khan academy especially when
the pandemic hit and i think were
finally surfacing from it
but allowed us to really
do things like homeroom and provide
support for almost 3x the users that we
were seeing with the pandemic hit so
special thanks to att general motors and
fastly for that and and all of our other
supporters who really keep khan academy
going as a not-for-profit and last but
not least a reminder that there's a
podcast version of this live stream
available wherever you get your podcast
homeroom with sal the podcast
and now with that i'm excited to
introduce you to regina ross khan
academy's chief people officer hey
regina
hi sal i'm glad to be here
so before we jump into questions i
remind everyone whether you're watching
on uh youtube facebook or i believe
we're actually live streaming on
linkedin today
put your post your questions our team
members are going to help surface it to
me so that i can get to regina topic is
about leadership about managing
organizations etc etc but regina i
always like to start
uh pretty early in people's journey if
you could tell us a little bit about
what you were like as a kid where did
you grow up did you think you would be a
chief people officer one day do you even
know what that is tell us a little bit
about what yourself is as a child
very interesting question so i um i
loved um and thrived in the academic
setting
i was a nerd a smart kid
loved school
my father was in the military so we did
travel a bit
but then
we landed in at home in montgomery
alabama and that's where i went to
school graduated there
i was part of the gifted program
throughout elementary school and i loved
math and science
and so this really led to my journey
into engineering did you know you knew i
was an engineer right
that's why we one of the reasons why one
of the many reasons
we definitely connected on
yeah
yeah love to travel and let me just tell
you the story so i
um was really really um adept at math
and science and i had a high school
chemistry teacher
who says hey regina you should attend
this minority introduction to
engineering program might program it was
a two-week introductory program at
auburn university and that really opened
my eyes to the world of engineering
because i i really didn't know what an
engineer was so i was able to explore
different disciplines of engineering and
i landed on
industrial engineering because i love
the intersection of people and processes
so i attended aubrey university in
alabama didn't want to go too far away
from from home
but just just far enough away i
graduated summa [ __ ] laude and started my
engineering career and sal i tell you
even though
you know i did engineering continuous
process improvement mostly in
manufacturing i did transition into
operations leadership sales leadership
you know i was a regional logistics
manager
i have always had a passion for helping
people develop and maybe it's because of
the way that my chemistry teacher took
an interest in me and like hey you can
do more um so that's been my passion for
employee engagement leadership
development and i was eventually tapped
on the shoulder i was an operations uh
senior leader
at a big box retailer um and i'm like
hey regina
we want you to step into hr and so
because of my culture-focused leadership
i took the role and i fell in love with
hr say that i crossed over to the dark
side and i haven't looked back and the
thing about hr that i love sal is it
really enabled me to focus on connecting
talent and culture to the business
outcomes one thing you didn't know is
when i was a junior in college in my
engineering um pursuing my engineering
degree i wanted to shift majors i'm like
i want to do something to help people i
was thinking of being in ministry or
being a nun
something and my mom's like no you're
gonna finish your engineering degree and
so it was you know me stepping into hr
years later like okay i get it i'm able
to help people i'm able to drive
business outcomes and just seeing that
connecting um of my passion and my
purpose i love what i do
there's there's a bunch of really
interesting uh threads there and just to
connect with us because obviously
there's a lot of young people watching
this probably
young men and women watching this
probably trying to figure out okay is
this an interesting path for me how do
you navigate this i know in high school
college everyone has a lot of angst so
like what am i going to do with my life
and it sounds like you you found this
this passion for math and science uh
fairly early on i think it it helped
that you had other people believe in you
i definitely resonate with that part of
your journey and then uh industrial
engineering which i don't think a lot of
people know but to your point it's kind
of like
how do you optimize a factory you know
you you click you click on a button on
amazon now how does that how do they
figure out how to put the right thing in
the right package and get it to the
right place uh process design so it's
pretty broad uh you know the set of
things and then you went into what you
kind of called operations but that would
be more of like it still is process for
people in a lot of ways
and then you went into hr human
resources and i and i think this is
something i think i was a naive
initially when i uh
was coming straight out of college i'm
like okay i'm gonna go work for a
software company and that means that a
software company does nothing but write
software what do all these other people
do
and and i've now realized when you have
an organization uh human resources the
people function
its core because it's all about people
doing everything so how do you think
about
people operations or human resources to
someone who is naive like me in my early
20s
you know what that's what it is and i
was so fortunate sal when i
started at a particular company i won't
say the name um but i started as an
operations leader so this is what i'm
leaving my engineering career going into
operations leadership at a distribution
um organization and as a senior uh
leader i had to do some onboarding and
one of the courses was
thinking like an hr manager like what
you know i'm not an hr person but the
way that they put it together is that
you're not just leading or managing your
business processes you're leading and
managing a team of people who make it
happen um and i had some great mentors
who taught me regina if you take care of
the team
they will take care of the business and
take care of the client and so this is
why i think i had this culture-focused
leadership
mindset and approach that yeah i'm an
operations leader i'm an engineering
leader but at the end of the day it's
taking care of the people and sal when i
stepped into my first full-time hr
leader role if the the dots really
connected and i saw that potential of
really focusing full-time on
helping the culture and the people
deliver on the business priorities and i
will tell you the the khan academy job
posting that i saw it really resonated
with me and so
i didn't have a background in non-profit
i didn't have a background
in the educational industry so when i
saw the job posting i'm like i don't
know if i'm going to be a fit but there
is something in that that kept pulling
at me and i'm just going to read this
this verbiage that was from the job
description it said that um this this
role was to help foster a high
performance culture
and a great place to work that enables
employees to deliver their best work
towards attaining khan academy's mission
while fulfilling their personal
aspirations and career ambitions
dropped the mic that that was it for me
i was sold
and that's what i'm doing that's that's
why i'm so excited
to be here and it's not
so i love khan academy i love uh you
know what we do and my kids i use khan
academy with my kids because even though
i'm an engineer they struggle with math
and science i'm like go figure
um but i know of the benefit and the
beauty of this this product and what we
do
and when i saw this like the mission and
then you me and my role in people
operations and actually this statement
that i just read this is now our people
operations team mission statement about
really fostering that high performance
culture
a great place to work that really does
enable employees to deliver their best
work and so i'm just excited to be here
i love what i do i love khan academy
now i think there's a little bit of
lesson in there which is you know one
your journey already took a couple of
turns and even in that last age before
you came to khan academy there was a
little part of you said well i've never
worked at a non-for-profit i wasn't in
education but this thing really
resonated me so you were able to kind of
not not feel impostor syndrome and say
i'm going to try and and as we all know
you were you know we were excited we
were excited to hire you
uh but
you know that that reminds me of uh i
could have never guessed that i would
have been in this role either i remember
in business school
the business school i went to they
didn't really fail anyone but if they
did fail someone they give one twos and
threes in a class and the only class
that i got a three in was called social
entrepreneurship because no way
i was just i was so cynical about the
not-for-profit sector uh
back then and you know uh fate destiny
whatever irony would have it that this
is you know i plan on doing this the
rest of my life uh now so uh i think
everyone's life takes these twists and
turns i am curious and i always like to
get into the head every now and then i
or pretty commonly i meet people
teenagers people early in their careers
and there's so much uncertainty of what
they want to do with their life
if you could go back in time or at least
to send a message back in time to 20
year old regina or
uh 30 year old regina
what what would you tell them
yes and i'm glad you asked that question
because i have
spoken to like my kids you know and
other young people that i'm you know
mentoring and trying to help so so my
tips one would be to try different
experiences
and versus you know just sticking with
only one thing and only doing what you
know well so i've been in engineering
i've been in operations leadership i've
been in transportation i've done sales
leadership and like i don't like that i
don't want to do a sales leadership um
but it helped me to understand what i
liked and what i didn't like what i was
good at what i wasn't good at the second
thing i would say is build and leverage
a really strong support network i call
it a personal board of directors so you
have mentors sponsors advisors
um my career i wouldn't be where i am
were not for
like my chemistry teacher who i'm still
in touch with um you know people who
taught me strategic planning people who
taught me the the unwritten rules of of
the road in every corporation that i've
been at and so leverage that support
network one thing specifically for women
is that we tend to build the
relationships uh but according to how
women rise by sally helgeson is that we
don't leverage those we think it's you
know
not good for us to reach out and ask for
help so we've got to build our network
leverage the network um i would say
another tip or lesson learn
throughout my career is excel at the
right things
so i can't be perfect at everything i
know that i'm good at you know project
management and some things i'm not so
good at uh you know maybe email
management and so
it's about excelling at the right things
focus on what matters most so
particularly when you go into an
organization you're building your career
find out what's really important i've
seen um other women and i myself have
fallen into the trap of sometimes just
being heads down and just trying to get
a lot of work done
and you burn the candle at both ends and
you're trying to do a lot of work but
you're not focusing on what really
matters the most
another tip is know your worth and
advocate for yourself um this is
something specifically for women
and there's a lot of studies but one in
particular is women in the workplace by
mackenzie and lean in uh where there's
just the gap right and this is why we're
celebrating on international women's day
you know hashtag break the bias
so know your worth advocate for yourself
uh typically men will negotiate when it
comes to salary time or you know for
promotions and women we don't and so
it's just really important to make sure
that you know what it is that you want
that you advocate for yourself you
prepare yourself for
for that journey and for those greater
things
and this this one sound is so important
i think this last one is really defining
success on your own terms uh versus uh
you know just just avoid the comparison
trap because my journey
may be very different than someone
else's journey and that's okay
i have taken a lot of twists and turns
in my career and in my development i
wasn't really focused on chasing the
title or the promotion or you know
making this move here it was about me
and my experiences my total quality of
life and so i'm i'm
thankful and grateful for where i landed
um but i tell you there are times where
i look to the left and look to the right
like oh i should be at this level by now
or this person is doing that and i just
really had to you know hey let me define
success for myself
um
one thing i would say for
younger people is that they think
they've got to have it all mapped out
early on
and you really don't my kids struggled
with this they were
stressed out because maybe in as a
junior in high school they didn't know
exactly what colleges they were going to
go to and what they wanted to major in
this is a tool that i found maybe five
or six years ago but it's a japanese
concept called ikigai a japanese term
that means reason for being and i wish i
had this years ago
but what it does and this icky guy is
like a venn diagram
where you're looking to
um find that intersection between what
you love doing
what the world needs what you're good at
and then what you can be paid for and so
when you find that intersection that's
that sweet spot or that icky guy your
reason for being uh we're like okay i'm
i'm doing what i love i'm doing what i
can be paid for you know because some
people want to do
a certain career but then they they
can't make a living at it and so if you
can find that sweet spot
you are golden even if you can't find
that sweet spot in one job and this will
be the last thing i'll say uh sal and
turn it back over to you one thing i
learned from
one of my managers when i was a young
engineer was regina you may not find
everything that you need and get
everything you need out of this job so
make sure that you have other outlets
for your talents for your interest for
your passions and this is where you know
you get into volunteering or
you do some things on the side that are
really that fuel your passion so that
you're not getting frustrated because
you expect to get everything out of that
one job or out of that first job
and then you realize that you're not
getting everything that you want so
those would be my lessons to the younger
regina i wish i would have known these
things years and years ago
i i love it
and i mean
just to summarize it because i think you
could write a book about this regina you
know personal board of directors but
don't just have them leverage them
um
advocate for yourself i do have a
follow-up question about that because i
think that's an interesting thing for a
lot for a lot of folks men and women but
to your point it might be even a bigger
attention for some women but advocate
for yourselves uh
fine do things sustainably so you don't
burn both ends find your own swim lane
that's what i strongly strongly believe
and i wasn't really happy on my career
side until i had my own now i have
almost i have a very my own swim lane i
was in a very competitive swim lane
before as a hedge fund analyst and no
matter how much you succeed there
when you define yourself by um
comparison in that swimlane you're just
never going to be never really happy so
i love that swim lane and that last
piece is i often give a version of that
to a lot of young people just yeah make
sure you always have room for your
passions no one job is going to be able
to
check all the boxes and so you're kind
of overloading it and then setting it
making it unsustainable if you project
everything if you project on everything
onto it one question you know this is
something that i've struggled with in my
own career um
and you you know you mentioned this
especially important for a lot of young
women is to advocate for yourself and
it's often hard when you're in the
moment to say how hard do i advocate for
myself how hard ball do i play because
there is there is a point where if you
play too hard ball people say i'm sorry
you know like um and and you know i i've
often seen this even at khan academy
like at khan academy as you know we take
great pains that we say look if
someone's going to
be doing a job at a certain level
this is what we're going to pay them and
we have gotten in the situation where
you know someone's told us their comp
expectation is x and we're like well
this job we're going to pay you more
so it's you know we're not negotiating
we actually we're going to try to pay
everyone what's fair because even though
you could probably get away in the short
term with paying someone less if they
thought that that's what they were worth
at some point they're going to ask their
friends they're going to realize that
they were being undercompensated um and
even the people who are going to be paid
more for the same job were like wait
this isn't a fair place maybe i'm also
getting taken advantage somehow so as an
organization it i think super makes
sense to pay
if people are doing the same level same
performance same job
um
pay them pay them the same and be
transparent about it but you know
sometimes we have had situations where
people like well i need to negotiate
harder and we're we're trying to be very
transparent saying no we literally give
the same pay so
we don't want to be based on
negotiations so how what advice do you
have to someone where it's like they
want to negotiate they want to make sure
they're not taking advantage of which i
completely agree but also there could be
situations where
it might be less productive
yeah i would say one uh do your research
so you'll be well informed because you
may be asking for um and
a number that's just really unrealistic
so you know do your research be informed
and then know for yourself
like what is um
the non-negotiable what are you willing
to in
because that puts you in the power of
choice so you're not you're not um like
oh they they oh they only gave me this
and i had to accept this and i coach a
lot of young women
i know you're not having to accept this
you need to make a choice are you
choosing to accept it or are you not and
so and maybe you want this number and
your your bare minimum is like you know
what i think i could be satisfied here
then you make that decision of i'm going
to um
you know i'm going to be satisfied here
or i'm going to push for here and if i
don't get this level then i'm willing to
walk but you've got to have that
internal dialogue
and be very clear about
what your limits are what your
non-negotiables are and stand in that
power of choice so you're not feeling
like they did this to me or they made me
like no that no
you have a choice you always have a
choice either you accept it or you don't
right
yeah no it's really powerful i think i
think
i think throughout life whether it's
negotiating comp but just everything in
life um it is this i i still find this
tension of of how much do i advocate how
how
versus how much do i accept or
you know it is it is a hard tension but
i think the way i think being informed
is the right thing you know ask as many
questions
get zero in and then know what you
really want uh know what you really want
to deserve don't go into something if
you're feeling kind of bad about it on
day one
i think i'm getting i'm underselling
myself that's not gonna uh
set anyone up for success and i'll see
on the organizational side
you know this is what we try to do um
and you know regina you and i have a lot
of conversations about this how do we
make
comp more transparent so you can give
people the confidence that because the
worst thing you want is to be in an
organization or an environment where
you're you're you're wondering all the
time
of like well
was this right am i going to be taking
it
that's right yeah and you want to look
at the total picture
of not just your base salary but your
overall rewards you know your time off
your benefits your the quality of life
you know the type of environment i have
been in so many environments now where
we describe it as the golden handcuffs
well yeah i'm getting a big salary you
know a lot of stock and all that but
it's a toxic environment and so you got
to look at success for you in terms of
like total rewards
life experience quality of life all of
that and make the right decision for you
it makes a ton a ton of sense well we
have we have uh some some questions uh
going on here so i think this is a
question a lot of people are wondering
this is from stephanie on social media
with the pandemic having gone on two
years now what advice would you give to
people who are feeling burned out in
their job career etc
yeah
i i really like sal thank you stephanie
for that that question um this this
whole
icky guy exercise like really
taking that time to be you know
introspective of what do i really want
what am i passionate about what's what i
feel my purpose is am i
um you know in a space where i can
achieve that and if not
then evaluate do i need to make some
changes uh sometimes it may need to be a
job shift sometimes it may need to be
putting some boundaries um you know in
your personal life
but i i and we just don't even know we
think this year is going to be a great
year and we see you know still just more
um emotional trauma that we're all
having to deal with like evaluate what
you need and then determine what steps
actionably that you can take uh to get
what you need whether it's boundaries
whether it's getting additional help
whether it's doing something that uh
feeds your passion in volunteering
because the answer may look very
different from you stephanie than
someone else
you know that's that's great advice
and regina you know these these home
rooms especially when i talk to really
interesting guests like you go way
faster than i ever uh
but we're already running low on time
but maybe maybe just you know if you
could kind of take us out with
you heard stephanie's question i think
at all stages of people's careers
there's just like am i doing the right
thing yes all jobs have certain things
that you know you're not super pumped
about but it has other things that are
good
how have you navigated it when do you
know it's time to switch versus time to
just perceive what you're doing
differently or try to tweak what you're
doing within the job or any other advice
that you have for uh
young professionals or or women
everywhere
yeah um one so a couple of things one is
have your own like personal mission
statement this is something that i
learned from seven habits of highly
effective people like have my own
personal mission statement and then
continually evaluate
where am i am i tracking towards that or
am i not is the the job that i'm doing
the role that i'm serving the way that
i'm living
is it in alignment with that mission
statement am i moving towards my purpose
or am i not sometimes we have detours
and i just say evaluate you know the
pluses and the deltas and in your
current situation you know do the pluses
outweigh the deltas all right or
vice versa if the deltas or the
negatives outweigh the pluses then it
may be time for a change and you um are
the only person who can determine that
there's a great person dr kim says if
you always do what you've always done
then you'll always get what you've
always got and only you can determine
if that is enough so this is what i
would leave you with evaluate where
you're going
is it enough and if it's not make a
change
i love that if you could send me that
quote there's it's obviously
obviously true quote but the something
about the phrasing that is so
it's very poignant
well
well regina thank you so much for taking
the time out uh i think as everyone can
tell uh i feel blessed and khan academy
is blessed to have you as our chief
people officer and i look forward to
going on this journey together both
helping support the team at khan academy
in our journey to hopefully support tens
or hundreds of millions of people around
the world uh but also be able to do
things like this and share your wisdom
with you know so many other people on
the planet thank you so i'm so glad to
be here
well thanks everyone uh for joining i
know i haven't been doing these
homerooms too frequently i'll try to do
a few more more frequently it's no
longer the daily homeroom definitely
when we started doing the pandemic but i
hope you you got is as inspired as i did
from regina and i gotta say as someone i
work very closely with on on a
day-to-day basis i've already learned so
so much from her uh and and you know
this this is one of the best things
about my job getting to work with regina
and people like regina and how we can
then empower empower others so with that
see you later onward
you